foreign
it's 11 so thanks for staying awake
through the first hour of the tutorial
this will be the uh the second
um where we will make use of the bound
that we have derived from the first hour
in order to
explain one notion of optimality
of evaluating these queries
uh so I'm going to tell you about three
classes of algorithms uh uh I am going
to name them jat vat and yet
I think this is the first time that they
occur in the literature so I'm very
proud of this accordance
this is one reason I I didn't want to
give work and the slice beforehand
because you know some elements of
surprise is more interesting
uh okay so let's let's go uh talking
about um joint so I mentioned this um
before
so we we've fixed a query and for now
let's just say it's a full conjunctive
query
and we have a statistical profile which
is basically just a set of degree
constraints and we want to compute the
output
and one notion of voice guys of
optimality is that um if the runtime of
the algorithm
is the input size plus the worst case
output size then that could be one way
you might be you know defining a notion
of optimality
and in a database literature we
typically
hide some you know poly law factors and
also some factors that depend on the
size of the query and because the query
is considered to be a lot smaller than
the database
but this this Factor could be humongous
in in practice and we really have to
care about them but for the purposes of
this talk uh I will kind of ignore
factors that depend on the query size
for them
um
okay so there will be a hierarchy of
algorithms which I will call them uh one
join at a time one variable at a time
and one inequality at a time so that
explains the acronyms and the main theme
of The Talk will be that you can
actually find the algorithm in the
pudding so the proof is in a pudding and
then if you look into uh the pudding
you'll find the proof and from the proof
you get the algorithm
or putting
uh all right so uh we'll see how we can
turn the proof of the you know into an
algorithm and this will be the central
theme of The Talk
all right so remember that we had this
hierarchy of bounds I didn't describe
some of the other bounds but effectively
what is going to happen is the following
we have algorithms that meet uh some of
these bombs so for example if you go
back to this quantity
we did we didn't really know how to
compute this quantity right because you
know it's the entropic bound and
approximation and it is maybe too hard
to compute so what we'll do is we we
take the upper bound of this an
approximation of this uh it will be a
little bit worse than this
um uh for some queries and if the
runtime matches the upper bound then the
runtime would be worse case optimal if
that bound is tight under certain
constraints okay so when we have a
hierarchy of bonds like this uh you will
see that for example for the integral
Edge cover bound uh a jet algorithm will
achieve it for the AGM bound or chain
bound a vat algorithm variable at a time
to achieve it for the polymer bound
um the only algorithm known is an
inequality at a time algorithm
and these would be what is optimal
depending on what you assume about the
query and what you assume about the
constraints so as if the bound is tight
then that algorithm is worst case of the
most
but we have a kind of a hierarchy of
bounds and and algorithms like this
so in some sense every algorithm is
voice guys optimal depends on what you
assume about the query and uh
okay so let's look at jar algorithm and
I'm going to explain just one slide on
this
So In traditional databases uh what
happens is suppose that you have a
triangle query like this RAB SBC TUC
a typical query plan will say that well
I will have to look for a query plan in
which I will join
two relations at once and uh Yuri asked
about what a join means it just means
when we are joining let's say RNs that
means we are looking for all triples ABC
for which a B is in R and BC is in s so
that's that's
a satisfaction problem
and the traditional databases are built
on this kind of binary join plan so so
this is a query plan that says why don't
we join RNs first we look at all the
triples ABC for which ABC and BC is in s
and then we take the result of that we
join with s
right or you could have this plan you
join smt first and then r or join our
Nest first and then t
now it turns out that for this input no
matter which pair you join first you
will get an output of size quadratic but
this is obviously not uh
voice guys optimal because it is lower
than what higher than what the bound
predicts right answer 1.5
so obviously a chart algorithm is not
going to be worse case optimal for this
for this one
so this is the only slide I have on Jack
Africa
so let's look at the next class of
algorithms uh variable at a time
and here
um so as a reminder in the last lecture
we showed the following given this
triangle query
the size of the output is bounded by
basically R to the Lambda RS Lambda T
given that the Lambda is a fraction of
edge cover for the triangle
so the sum of every pair of them is at
least one and then the lambdas are
non-negative
this came from the AGM bar or faction of
edge
and obviously if you plug in an actual
graph you could get something like equal
to 1.5
so let's see how you can prove this
bound but not using the entropic
approach like before we are going to
give a different proof of this mode and
there's no proof is going to be very
naturally turned into an algorithm it's
extremely natural hopefully I will
convince you of that
so let's consider one section of this
query so this is triangle query but I'm
going to consider the section that
corresponds a particular value in the
domain of the variable way
so this is like a sub query where we
specialize it to just one single value
and uh so now if we want to list all of
the triples ABC for which the section is
true right
so then um what we need is basically all
of the pairs B and C for which the
little B is in you know in in r
uh which is the projection of R onto the
part of our where a is little a
right and then BC itself has to be in s
right and then C has to be in the
projection of T onto the C column
right so that means that we need BC in
this intersection it has to be in s and
intersecting with the cross product of
the projection of r on to B and
projection of s onto C
in this intersection
is it goes like
this is around the product right that's
right yeah so the the parenthesis should
be around this crossbody so s is on
which C Dimension and then this copper
is also okay that should be e
H it should be oh I'm sorry yeah
okay so as intersecting with uh with our
projection of R cross product with
projection
three but uh
with a fixed value right
okay so here's a trivial observations
the the number of such BCS because it's
in the intersection of two sets it is
going to be smaller than the smaller of
the two steps
the intersection of two sets is always
bounded by the minimum of the two sets
uh and the minimum of the two sets is
you know there's a cross product right
so you can multiply them like this right
now the minimum of two quantities of two
non-negative quantities is going to be
bounded by the geometric mean so I can
put in Lambda s here and one minus
number is here
so the Min is bounded by the geometric
mean
and finally because Lambda S Plus Lambda
R is more than one right so now I can
replace 1 minus Lambda s by Lambda r
and also uh Lambda S Plus Lambda T is
more than one because of the fraction of
edge cover so this can be replaced by
Lambda t
so now we have
for this section uh this is upper
bounded by this right
oh this is just above around one section
of the query
so far
so okay
now all we have to do to bound the
actual query sizes to some over all
possible A's right because we are
summing over one one I at a time so it's
just something over all possible ways
and now we are replacing this with the
one we just got from the previous slide
right and then we can factor out s to
the Lambda s
and we have this quantity
and now we apply holder because Lambda R
plus Lambda T is more than one so you
can push the sum inside the product uh
inequality
and now this is the sum over all of the
a sections of R so which is just R and
sum over a sections of T is just T so
that's that's how we get the fractional
Edge cover bound
without using the entropy argument
okay so the beauty of this proof is that
it actually turns into an algorithm it's
really naturally because all we did was
well uh if you want to proof a bond like
this let's just iterate over all values
of a and then for every a fine you know
BCS in this intersection right
so that's what the algorithm is the
algorithm is in the burning is it
putting a pudding
anyway so what we do is we iterate over
all A's uh in common between R and T
and then iterate over omb's iterative OC
condition on that a
right so it's like a conditional search
algorithm or backtracking search
condition on a look for the B which are
known A and B for the C
so it's just backtracking search and um
well in English all we are doing is uh
for every eye let's basically enumerate
over ABC's uh in this section of the
query I'm sorry there should not be this
vertical boss here I will fix the uh
this is just kind of the selection of
the the output but on on equal to little
y okay
and uh how long does this algorithm take
well it actually can almost but um
genetically from the proof of the upper
bound
so the algorithm uh we are iterating
over a little A's right and then
we can compute the intersection of two
sets in the time that is proportional to
the smaller of the two sets because you
can iterate over a smaller set and look
up in a bigger set
with the law Factor loss and so the
search time can be is basically this
much but now I'm just repeating the
proof that we just did for the upper bar
because once you have the Min then you
can replace it by uh you know the
geometric mean and then you know apply
holder to get this quantity
um and so the runtime is exactly as
predicted by the bomb it came exactly
from the proof of
um
okay uh any questions so far
that's just for the triangle uh right
so now uh what about in general well
it's identical the proof is virtually
identical to the triangle case except
that we have now a fractional Edge cover
of the hypograph of the query right and
then the bound looks something like this
a product over R to the Lambda you know
our s to the Lambda s there's one Lambda
for every Edge in the hypergraph
there's something about the triangle
order
it does not the algorithm does not
depend on the values of Lambda
on the value of what the lambdas and the
oil and bits and the S they do not
intervene in the algorithm is a
decisions
yeah a good question so the question was
the algorithm uh yeah so as long as the
Lambda is formed a fraction of edge
cover and this is an upper
which is
okay so the the general algorithm
follows precisely the same script
um we take the fractional Edge cover
there's one Lambda for every relation in
the in the input
and then you can condition on one
variable value of one variable right so
then you are partitioning the query into
two parts the parts that depend on the
variable which is here and the parts
that does not depend on the on the
variable
so that's the the section
and we can basically by induction we sum
over so this is the proof of the of the
inequality so we just sum over these
sections right so the sum is broken up
into two uh
the product of two things things that
not depend on the age and the things
that depend on a and then applying
holder we will get exactly this this
amount
it's precisely the same proof
and and then the algorithm is also the
same you just say that well why don't we
iterate over
all of the values in uh the of the
relations are content this variable a
and for each one of them recursively
uh compute the little section on the
variables that are not a
and then we just report that section
along with the value a and then the
runtime follows precisely from from the
proof
um
okay so that's that's basically uh the
vat algorithm one variable at a time
algorithm
okay
um now the ATM bound as is actually does
not apply
uh
uh four degree concerns that are Beyond
cardinality constraints however we can
generalize this algorithm a little bit
to um to the chain bound which um which
is basically a bound that has you know a
variable ordering that I skipped over
from the previous uh lecture so I'm not
going to have time to go through this
but I just wanted to point out that this
algorithm actually applies to an
arbitrary query
under one extra assumption which is that
you have to supply it with a variable
ordering to you know your condition on
my I first and then B and then C and so
on and this variable ordering has a
humongous effect on the runtime of the
algorithm
and the problem of deciding which
variable ordering to to choose from is
NPR and that's one of the main tasks of
the query Optimizer to choose the right
value
so for any variable order
your algorithm would be worst case
it's just that in practice there may be
huge differences between the Bible yeah
so Dan's question was
um
the effect of or comment with the I
think the variable ordering on the worst
case optimality of the algorithm and yes
it's correct
four cardinality constraints only
then the variable ordering does not have
any effect on voice automatic
however if we go beyond cardinality
constraints then the variable already
also has an effect on the worst case
automatically because
um yeah
for you for some conference if you
follow you know one particular order you
might activate that constraint but if
you select a different variable
and that has an effect on on the worst
case right now
okay so so now let's come to let's have
a little detour of
um before describing uh
if I had projections in the query
what breaks down here
uh yes so the question is what if we we
have a projection on the query um so the
two things I will break down one is on
the worst case size bound on the output
will will break because you know if the
query is a Boolean query
so in the third lecture welcome I
interpret the tutorial I'll come to
for now let's just stick to
um
okay so before describing this uh most
probably most interesting class of
algorithms yet
we have to talk about
um a Shannon flow inequalities
all right so a little reminder that we
you know so we describe an algorithm to
achieve the AGM bound we say that it can
also acute for chain bone but now let's
uh let's talk about the polymer motor
Bond and see if we can actually achieve
a runtime that's predicted by this uh
which which can be you know a lot better
than the other two valves
remember that our goal is still here
right but we have no idea how to do this
in general so we kind of had to relax
things all the way up to here and let's
let's try to achieve this amount first
um okay so this was a theorem that I
quoted earlier
um that the bound at the output size is
bounded by
um the maximum overall polymerase that
satisfy the degree constraints
and the degree concerns of this form so
h of Y given X is less than equal to log
n
right so the degree constraints are now
converted into a constraint a linear
constraint on this space of vectors or
space of functions
as a vector space this has an
exponential number of components
right so let's write it down more
explicitly what do we mean by uh you
know polymatory what do we mean by
degree concerns
so the problem is we want to maximize h
of V which is a set of all variables
subject to the degree constraint so you
know hfy minus h of X is less than the
log n so here I'm assuming that Y is a
superset of x just to remove the
annoying you know why Union legs every
time
this is without loss of generality
so this is a degree constraint and then
we have to write down the other three
constraints that are from the
polymerican threads so the first one is
submodularity all this is saying is you
know each of um
uh if you condition one more then you
will get the condition conditional
entropy to be reduced
if you know more than the degree of
uncertainty will become less that's
that's what submodularity means
um so that's this constraint
and then the next one is that is
monotonicity it says that h of X is less
than h of Y if x is a subset of Y so
obviously the degree of uncertainty when
you have more variables is going to be
more than the you know degree or
uncertainty when you have less variables
that's what this means and then entropy
is non-negative of course I'm talking
about entropy but these are only poly
Matrix
the inspiration of where these
inequalities come from these are
commission and inequalities they all
come from the and the information
interpretation of these quantities
um okay so now the first thing we want
to do is actually create a dual variable
for every of these linear constraints
and there's one Delta for every degree
concerns there's one for every
um
submodularity constraint and this is
overall pairs i j for which uh
I is not a subset of J and J is not a
subset of Y so there's a lot of these
eyes
it's quadratic exponentially quadratic
or quadratically
and then there's a
monotonic City
Trend it has a mu Duo variable so there
are three sets of dual variables Delta
Sigma and mu
and now when we write down the duo of
this linear program the one way to solve
this linear program is doesn't solve the
Dual right
it will have the following form
so this will be Min over uh the dot
product between the Delta and the the
log of the decrease
this is very much like in the fashion
Edge cover wow right and you take the
duo is precisely the same quantity in
the fashion range compound
except that the constraints are more
complicated
complicated because in the professional
Edge cover band you just have you know
fractional Edge covers uh
here uh there are you know there's one
constraint for every subset of variables
and I will not bother you with going
through the details it's just basically
there's one constraint for every subset
of variables
and it measures a certain excess of flow
going to that subset of value
and here's a picture of how to you know
measure excess so if you have for
example a subset of variable Z then all
of the sigma for which Z is at the
bottom of the sigma of this diamond is
going to contribute positively to the
excess of Z and that is also a negative
contribution so if you would like to
kind of have a pictorial illustration of
how these excesses come about then we
just look at this picture
um I I wouldn't expect you to kind of
get the details of this I just want to
to get you know a theorem statement out
of the Dual formulation
okay so now now that we have the Dual
variables uh
now um we are ready to define something
called a Shannon flow inequalities
so so given the Deltas uh these are
basically you know the Dual variables
corresponding to the the degree
constraints right given a non-negative
deltas
then if the following quantity holds for
uh for every polymatory so if h of B is
less than uh you know Delta uh were
given X
times the conditional entropy or
condition of polymetroid H of Y given
next if this inequality holds for every
polymer right
then it is called the Shannon flow
inequality
by definition so so
um for some Deltas this inequality will
not hold for every polynomial some other
Delta it will hold for everyone and for
those we are going to call them the
shunt flow inequalities
uh so it is known the following is known
that Delta defines a channel flow
inequality if and only if you can extend
it
to dual feasible this is the reason why
I had to define the Dual LP just now
so this is kind of a
equivalent characterization of of the
Deltas so you can
what is
um V is a set of all variables
foreign
[Music]
now so here's one thing that you might
be able to relate to that if the degree
concerns are all cardinality constraints
that means the expert is all empty
then these are precisely the Shiro's
Lemma
so for those of you who are familiar
with Shiro's Lemma is basically an
inequality of this form where it's you
know the coefficient on the right hand
side will have to form a fractional Edge
cover
and that that holds for all volumetrics
so this is a generalization of serious
Lemma
into General Degree concerns so it's not
just cardinality concerns but you know
the ex part can be non non-empty also
okay so that's a go ahead
so for the variables of one relation
right here I see h of Y minus h o is so
how can I recover h of X Y let's say
right so the question was Insurance
Lemma we only have you know like Delta
times h of Y has no X in it
uh but uh if x was empty then h of X is
zero so that's how we
okay so you know as soon as you see an
example it'll think
so the first example of a Shannon flow
inequality is a triangle example again
but in this case we express it in in the
following way uh so h of a b c is less
than half of Hab plus HBC plus HAC
and this inequality holds for every
polymerton
in three dimension
and we can give a proof of this actually
uh very simple
so the this proof uh I think probably a
lot of people have come up with this
proof like on their own but uh the first
time I learned about this uh this proof
style was from a really interesting
paper Radha Krishnan 2003 uh entropy and
Counting
um and it goes something like this so we
start from the right hand side
and then
um we do the following so h of IB might
you can write it in a telescoping way
right new h of a plus h of IB minus h a
so that means that this is just a
conditional entropy of B given a right
so this is a decomposition of H of a b
into two terms
and then uh we apply sub modularity
so here hrbc map down uh h of Bim moved
it over here AC moving over here so the
only thing that I applied was h of a is
more than h of a condition on BC
because when you condition on more the
entropy will reduce the degree of
uncertainty will be reduced
so so that's submodularity but now you
can group these two together you know
this is a composition step so now h of a
given BC plus age or BC just like this
guy here right here is H of ABC
and now we have one term on the right
so far we've got one h of ABC on on the
left hand side yeah
and now let's look at this term we apply
submodularity again so now we condition
on both A and C so uh entropy will be
reduced and apply composition again we
get a second term on the left hand side
so now we have test proof the inequality
this goes to this
uh so basically you know in in this
tutorials you see like different ways to
prove the same thing and then each one
of those ways turns out to give you kind
of an algorithmic idea in some sense
okay uh so that's for the triangle query
now I'm not going through this in detail
but you can verify at home that
this is no longer
a Shearer Lemma type of thing right this
this inequality actually holds for
uh all polymer toys on four variables
uh this was from them actually Dan came
up with great examples as always
um and you can kind of Trace through the
steps of this algorithm and you you can
see that starting from this right hand
side you just do decomposition
submodularity composition and and so on
there are only three three things that
you can do it's like a an infant rule
you just keep applying these infant
rules and eventually you end up with one
side of the you know inequality from the
other side
it's not obvious that this always exists
however for the two examples that we
have seen uh actually the you know these
steps exist right now
in general to have a
way to explore the space of possible the
steps you apply there through to try to
prove whether an inequality exists or
not
is there something like that in this
case I guess this is the open question
animation
right uh so I I think there are two ways
to phrase your question so one is you
know how do we kind of come up with the
proof of an inequality uh given that we
didn't know it beforehand whether or not
the inequality is valid right and I
think uh Raymond young and others have
worked a lot on like a software system
to to go discover inequalities at all
not only for polymer toys but also for
uh now in general given an inequality
like this you could use the previous
thing that I mentioned to to verify it
because you know Delta Define an
inequality if and only if uh you you
know there exist Sigma in you so that
this is neural visible
so you could go about solving a little
program to decide validity
however there's a very very subtle
difference
here we were talking about kind of a
liberalization of the steps
now typically when you're Technology
Program you have to take a linear
combination of of Dooms and strength to
come up with the inequality but this is
a very specific like linearization of
these you know the leader combination
and they are not the same
uh uh so in in general
um
searching for this is so like the chase
in database because you have the infant
rule right so you kind of Chase these
words but you may end up with something
you know maybe even higher than what you
want the proof so I think it's it's an
interesting and good question in General
on how to to apply these three rules
like repeatedly in some ways to come up
with a group not obviously
I didn't quite understand the questions
like are they so they're maybe valid
inequalities that are not provable via
decompositions of modularity and
competitions
uh well we have a theorem that shows
that you can always come up with that
okay but it's not an obvious okay so the
difficulty is that if you uh so that
this inequality is a sum of some
modularity and uh monopolitical
qualities easy so you can find out some
uh
the problem is that if you compute the
partial sums you might get Negative
negative negative terms
and if you want to think about another
mean nothing to you
that is not obvious that you can
come over there
might be automatic view recruiting so
that's a problem
here telling me if you give me a bunch
of the accents and ultimate uh my proof
yeah yeah great comment yeah so the
chase is probably you know a special
case of
we said there was a software that does
this or does something like that
uh yes so there was software that um
kind of tried to come up with a
verification of the validity of entropic
inequality okay so you're given the
quality and then you have to verify
automatically verify if it's correct or
not what's the name I will send a link
uh okay so
um so now in general so let's just
summarize so we can show The Following
so what we are interested in is a
polymer round right and by taking a Duo
you can write it as a top product of the
Delta and the log of decrease
and from this Delta we know that this
inequality uh is a Shannon flow
inequality that means that it holds for
all polymer toys so this is all we know
so far
and
um it turns out that you can prove that
inequality we can come up with a proof
sequence just like in the two examples
that we have just shown
one step at a time you can do uh you
know the decomposition well yeah this
will be a composition right you you
compose two terms into one you can do a
decomposition you decompose h of Y into
h of X plus h of Y given X you can do
Sub sub modularity
and then this
um I didn't show this in in the examples
but you can also use the
monotonic city to replace a bigger term
by a smaller term and in this sequence
you will go from from a bigger sum to a
smaller sum and eventually you get to
the left hand side of the inequality
that's a proof sequence and uh there is
a Lemma from our paper in 2007 with
wooden done that shows that there is a
proof sequence for every flow inequality
now if you are looking for open problem
this is a great open problem so the
length of this proof sequence is is
terrible and I don't even remember the
formula maybe multi members but it is
very very big and we don't know how long
the proof sequence is
okay but why does this uh have anything
to do with uh join algorithms right so
now let's go you know proof is in the
pudding let's go to a joint algorithms
um
which is the uh yet algorithm
so um the essence of the idea is the
following so given a proof sequence for
the Shannon flow inequality we will come
up with a join algorithm to compute the
query
and it goes like this so
um every step in the proof sequence will
be turned into a relational operator
like a join or a projection or
partitioning
so if we have a composition of two
things then this will become a join
operator
if we have a decomposition then this
this will become partitioning the data
into parts
uh if we have a move from you know a
bigger term using monotonic City from
you know h of Y down the H of X this
will become the projection
and uh if it's submodularity then just
you know it's just a rearrangement of
things
so using this conversion
we we proved basically I came up with an
algorithm this is called Panda that
shows any conjunctive query in time that
is predicted by the polymer bar
okay so let's look at two examples and
it will have just enough time to go
through these two examples one of them
is a just a triangle query
so it should be very easy and you
probably have seen this algorithm before
and um okay so it goes like this so we
have a triangle query R uh s and t
let me Define this first beforehand so
our heavy
is the part of R for which the degree of
of a is more than square root of n
and R light is the part of R for which
the degree of a is less than blue n
let's just partition the R into two
parts the part that contains the heavy
eaters by heavy I mean the ones whose
degree is more than root n
and the light hitters uh the ones that
are less than rooted which is a
partition bar into two parts this may be
a little bit magic at this point but I
will explain how we came up with this to
begin with okay but for now let's just
say um
uh we we have this partition uh you know
someone gave us the idea
one of them is light yeah yeah
this is the right one so every part is
the one is
okay so now I'm going to use the proof
sequence
to turn it into a
way to compute the output
but um the way to do that is the
following so for every term on the right
hand side of the channel flow inequality
we will associate it with it a copy of
one of the input relations so h
a b correspond to RAB HAC is SBC ah
HBC is SBC and then HAC is Tac
I'm sorry
but now let's focus on this term first
because we in the proof sequence we
apply the decomposition step to this
term first
so we decompose this into h of a plus h
of B given a
now what does this correspond to well
this will correspond to essentially
decomposing R into two parts the heavy
part in the light part
I'm just chasing the colors now
now let's look at the next step The Next
Step was
submodularity so you know a was replaced
by a condition on BC
so this corresponds to doing nothing
except for a little bit of rearrangement
where we are about to
um
to compose these two terms together so
that will correspond to joining the
heavy are heavy and s b c now it
corresponds precisely in a one-to-one
manner on the proof sequence to a joint
operator
okay so in inequality we compose those
two into this joint right
and in the database we are going to join
our heavy with SBC into
an intermediate result I'm going to call
this eye heavy of ABC
again the join means you know I'm going
to compute a table
ABC for which
ABS in our heavy and BC is enough
that's just a join operator
and the next step is submodularity
corresponds to nothing
uh just some rearrangement and then
finally when we're about to compose
these two
uh to get hfibc then here we get the
intermediary zones corresponding to the
light branch of the environment
so I've just describe to you kind of how
the correspondence between the two the
inequalities the proof and the
association between every term and some
relation
so you didn't join them with tea at any
points
great question so I will explain why
this is correct
requests
yeah so the question was the proof
sequence can be very very long
definitely exponential and the algorithm
is well that's that's when this because
of theory is hiding all of the factors
that are dependent on the query
I don't know yeah so anything that's
dependent on quality size is kind of you
know
another rock
okay so I'm going to answer your
question why is this even correct right
so here's here's another proof that this
is
now I'm going to give you a precise
credit line of corresponding
and it goes like this
so the real query plan is when you do a
decomposition right you basically turn
this term into a union of two things
right
this is kind of like a um I
yeah it's just a motivator partitioning
right now once you turn yourself into a
union of two things and you can
distribute the or over the end and uh
and now we have two terms right the
heavy is on one side and the light is on
the other side
and then the next thing that we were
going to do according to the sequences
you join the heavy with s so now you
have the I heavy on one side so we
haven't lost anything yet and then on
the other side we have the the light
part of the query
and in the end obviously once you have
to compute this you will have to kind of
uh on the heavy side you have to filter
the result with t you have to do the the
join again but the last join the trivial
because once you have a relation that
spans all variables and we just you know
scan over it and if you don't have no
results
uh so that's the query plan that's the
actual algorithm
and the beauty of this is that you can
show that the the size of the heavy side
is less than n to the three over two and
uh similarly for size of the right on
the light side uh so let's enter three
over two
and that's precisely because of the way
we defined heavy and Light
right uh so for heavy for example
it was all of the IBS for which a degree
was more than root n
so the number of A's whose degree is
more than root n has to be less than
rooted
you cannot have too many heavy eyes
right otherwise it will be more than the
size of r
and so because the number of is uh
heavier is less than root ends when you
join these two together you will get
something smaller than enter one point
similarly for the light part the light
part is easier so here the degree of a
is less than root n so for every eye you
have utmost root and B's and then you
multiply that with the size of s which
is and
um
or is it the other way though
I I should probably Define the degree
with respect to B but I think you'll get
the idea yeah so oh no no it's fine this
is a joint with uh with T so yeah for
every Aid at most Rule and B right and
then we are going over N Things in in AC
right so for every IC Tuple the number
of B's is root n and so the the light
part is at most end of the
Cleveland
okay so that's the um that's the essence
of the one inequality at the time
at the time algorithm is there a general
way to tell which is the threshold
like awesome so my next example is is
about how to tell what this threshold is
because in general you know R could be
very different from n right and S could
be like really big or it's very small T
is no it's arbitrine so how do we even
tell what the threshold is the root n
was a very convenient way of Designing
fashion but in a database with arbitrary
degree concerns the threshold can be you
know very wildly different
so the next example is meant to
illustrate that
um so this comes from the following
query
we have a part of line three so ibe EBC
CD and then let's say we have the silly
hash function for every AC I get a d
right some kind of hash function and
then from every BD you get an A so we
don't know the reason I push harsh here
is so that you cannot do the reverse
lookup from the to
recover AC okay
um okay so so this query uh that's
actually the corresponding Channel flow
inequality I didn't show you the proof
steps on this national flower inequality
because it's a bit too long
but
um from this what you can do is the
following you know that HIV is smaller
than log R right so you can plug it in h
of BC log s h of C D not t
now the hash function means that the
entropy of D given AC is zero because
it's a functional dependency so you can
put in 0 here and zero here so you know
that the query size is bounded by square
root of i s and t
from this uh Shannon flow inequality
so now let's try to come up with a
algorithm that will answer this query in
this time
this is becoming a little less trivial
now you cannot do the one variable at a
time algorithm anymore
so we just change through the steps now
and again I'm not going through these
steps in in every in any detail But to
answer Albert's question earlier
um the algorithm will go kind of like
this right it's just you know chasing
through the query Planters like before
but the main question is how do we even
Define this heavy and light so that the
runtime is as predicted by the linear
program right so let's say that I solved
the linear program and I have this
optimal solution H star
let's say
um so what we can do
is the heavy part of s is going to be
defined by exactly the quantities that
came out of this entropy that's optimal
learning program
so it came out of the you know the
solution to
um to the polymer
so this is the heavy part this is a
light part it says you know the
threshold is defined that way
and it turns out that you know if that's
the case and you can kind of Chase
through the proof and you show that
um you know this the size of the
intermediate relations you know slide
join with t or as high Vision with r
they are going to be bounded by uh in
this case h star of BCD and this is H
star of ABC
so you have to start with the Primal
optimal solution and the Dual optimal
solution and because of that due to uh
complementary selectness you will get
this equality out yeah so the analysis
is is kind of easy but it's not um you
really have to delve into the details of
the linear program
to to know for sure that you get an
equality here and the runtime of the
bound of the all of the intermediate
results are really upper bounded by the
pollination amount
so I will upload the slides and you can
kind of Chase through the details once
you get it
okay so that's kind of uh two uh
illustrations of how Panda work now in
panda in reality it's much uglier than
this unfortunately
uh
because of the following I'm not going
to read through this slides because of
the following so when you come up with a
query plan like this
you have to make sure that every time
you partition or something into heavy
and light they will end up in like a
distinct branches of the security plan
but you cannot like recombine like a
heavy and the light part of the same
thing back together you essentially have
to to show
that in every Branch so every time you
do a partitioning you basically
partition the thing into two parts right
and then you partition again you will
get two parts from here to apart from
here you have to make sure that in the
end every term will end up with with the
the output it's a little bit hard to
describe but you can see from from this
that is not obvious that every proof
sequence is going to end up with a
correct result
right because what if you get stuck
somewhere in the middle
so that's basically the intrinsic
difficulty of realizing this idea in
general so we had to kind of make a
compromise uh where instead of just a
heavy light partitioning with Partition
relation into a logarithic rhythmic
number of circulations and the thing has
a polynomial poly law Factor as it's
very um very big okay
um but I hope you you get kind of the
gist of of this idea go ahead
my collection is also have for us to
partition on intermediate relations
right so we also get for those
elevations the real Nations what is the
actual threshold
s from the organization solution right
uh yeah so um yeah so in in Panda we we
have like a partitioning of this light
until you know I like like I like heavy
and so on right but the same proof
strategy will still flow through you can
think of it as a kind of an induction
right if
if your truth works for this term
uh and your proof works for this term
then together they will work for the
original product so you can kind of
induct on on the qualifier and
repeatedly
to say anything about the case where you
don't really restrict yourself to
partition and implementations
essentially seems to be a simpler
approach I guess you you of course will
not get the bound you want but uh
anything about these
praise God that they would be let's say
you know
that's the way we know of a few classes
of queries for which the decomposition
steps already happened in the beginning
uh such as environment and you only have
to do the composition of the
of the input relations you don't have to
to decompose an intermediate relation
uh but in general I think it's still
open like characterized precisely for
which degree concerns you can only do
this
in the beginning and you don't have to
decompose an intermediate
it
if I remember correctly Marxist original
algorithms that
dates are hard like you know that is a
modular but some modular uh all of the
sub modular width did that partitioning
but then I think you couldn't get they
couldn't get to the exact to the exact
type bound right because here
we will do achieve the exact bound so
there they they were of some constants
so
uh yep so here are some open problems
along
the direction
um so as I mentioned earlier the proof
sequence link
still kind of terrible
um
and then you know in the pun the actual
algorithm we you know we had some steps
that are not as clean as as I would have
you believed uh yeah and there's a
humongous poly law Factor
uh it could be you can argue that maybe
there could be a more natural algorithm
than panda
and then um there's a conditional
Independence constraint that may
actually break up under two no this can
bring the bound even down below the
polymer bound so these are some of the
few open
uh problems that we have
um yeah so hopefully I get you kind of
enough of an overview of three classes
of algorithms and one algorithm that
meets the polymer member
and in the next lecture next tutorial
I'll talk about queries with projection
so far we have only done four
conjunctive queries and projections open
up a new can of worms really interesting
we'll see you at 2PM
[Applause]
so I mean if I understood it correctly
these approaches still have a high
complexity on the number of variables in
your query right
there's no issue in practice
yeah anything that is more than
quadratic is a publication in practice
yeah so for this bound actually this
lower bound that we want to establish
for the length of the sequence right
what kind of techniques do you have in
mind actually what kind of techniques
can be used for that
you know
yeah but is there anything known about
this uh
in terms of the length of the sequence
yeah I don't know
I actually had a simple question I asked
the expert so you have a channel
inequality
in medicine so now this you know this is
a sum of car modular inequality
it's a coefficient as well
uh
expresses linear inequality with which
coefficient are integers
as an integer combination of your
monotone inequalities
and for all examples we know uh that's
the case you only need integer
coefficients gives you an upper bound on
India
produced by the times of no there is
one of them I don't remember one only
five which is very very dense and that
has an example of an inequality which is
integer but you need production and
combinations of fraction as fractional
sub modularity inequalities
which means that the
attacking it goes beyond what you can
written about it
seriously it goes beyond what beyond
what you can reach a reason about just
the integers
so you mentioned there's one open
problem exploited conditional
Independence so but in your foreign
dependencies basically if you look at
the query and you take a separator a set
of variables that will partition a query
into a disconnected components right so
you know that you know if you condition
and condition on the separator then the
the components are independent
uh and you can write that down as an
equality constraint in the linear
program
that equality concern is different from
the uh degree constraints that we have
seen and if you add that into the you
know into the CBC it's no longer just h
y minus h of X less than n right it's
actually there are more constraints and
that will reduce this bound down but
then we don't know of a corresponding
algorithm to meet at the new body
does the generalization of the
Simplicity of queries using three width
with data
that would be the subject
I'll come back to uh
does the particular proof sequence like
I imagine there's a bunch of ways
to affect either you know meeting the
bound or like a practical
so if we can come up with an optimal
group Sequence then the runtime will be
much better than
you can you can join things into an
intermediate result it's too big bigoted
about
approximation of something can we do
something more or easier
I don't know
I think our polymer bond is all ready
and upper bound and the worst case
science so in sometimes we are realizing
that
or the chain Bound for example you know
then you have to go through that
foreign
[Music]
oh I guess you are thinking about the
approved complexity
angle I I believe that we need to know
and I know you're not a belief
s
algorithm or a variants
yes so implemented in a sense that you
can easily do query rewriting by hand
uh because you can kind of pick a query
plan that you come up with using
improving this inequalities and you can
write you know a SQL query or you know
real query following exactly these steps
and if you have the right threshold
uh uh and then it it can be pretty good
thanks so especially for cyclic queries
like click queries
so all you need is a compiler that
translated yeah
but I suppose that you need a partition
operator that is very well implemented
and you know if the data size is too
large the issue of gathering you know
data from multiple servers you have to
run into a lot of system issues in real
life
originally you said optimization means
you do not know the theory beforehand
but now you actually said okay but if we
have this query we have this hope and
then we can translate but I mean the
general problem is
yeah so in the optimizer we would
Implement a proof sequence discoverer
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]